go ahead and go live
okay hello everyone welcome to uh this
live stream my third one for today this
is
incremental language design for wolfram
language
um we've got a variety of topics here
geoposition picker is up first
right we have brett here to discuss it
okay so the cloud team has asked for a
functionality to
interactively select a location
okay and so these already
almost does it but it's not perfect so
so the question is what is the language
level interface to this but i mean that
they probably want something that can be
deployed in a cloud form
right right right i think that they will
use their own
maps etc but they need the symbol and
the syntax
okay so
let's say do we have a cloud person here
it just occurred to me
no no this was just carlo asked okay
discuss it here um
okay but so
what are the comparable functions i mean
it's a setup function we need somebody
from the front-end team here
i don't know what how's the setup how
does date setup work for example
that's the new that are being selected
yeah i mean
i mean is this going to be a pop-up
thing or is this going to be a thing
that works in line
that's an interesting question i i was
thinking of it as being a thing that
would
work in line but i mean i suppose the
new date selector
the date setter thing is a pop-up as
well
jose i don't remember i've seen it but i
i don't think it was um appeared i mean
you didn't see the full calendar the
entire time did you
no no no no it's not something that
shows a calendar it just shows um a menu
and you can select the number of the
date and a bit of the year
i have a bad feeling we do not have the
right people here to decide this
i mean we need we need people who know
about the design of dynamic controls
right i'm sorry i don't know i i mean i
can go to the page
um
i i was expecting we would discuss the
the implementability from the year side
because i think they expect
us to implement this thing uh
from our side as a variation well
i think i think we probably need to
include front-end people and we probably
need to include cloud people
because they probably have you know some
idea of what they expect it to look like
on the cloud
and you know if desktop is
you know we don't want to diverge too
greatly from that
i mean i think i don't know whether it's
a setter or whether it's something else
i mean
these are pop-out type things also
there's the question of the drawing
tools
you know mechanism um
you know where we have a you know a
molecule drawing thing
that can pop out wrong people here i
think
i mean and who's actually going to do
the implementation
i think this requires two separate
implementations and in
one probably based on something like
dynamic geographics which is probably
for
us the geo team and another one
in cloud they will have their own maps
right but i mean i'm assuming that
this is basically going to be
a version of dynamic geographics that
allows you to have
so i mean this is more like
let me look here presumably it's more
like a locator
well it's right like moving around right
now is
locator pane on top of
dynamic geographics
right
i mean it's also kind of like color
slider possibly
i mean i mean so you have color center
and color slider
and one of the differences between them
is you know so
whether it's a pop-up thing or an
in-place thing
right
i mean i'm kind of thinking it's some
sort of geographics pain
because i can imagine a case where you
actually don't care about the locator
right where basically what you're doing
is you're trying to capture
you just have dynamic geographics
without any locator there at all
and you're just trying to say okay go
pick the part of the world you care
about what i'm saying so you're going to
preserve the center
you know the the bounding rectangle
because that's information as well
i see what i'm saying yeah
could be even the country yes
yeah right which um you know
i like yes and you're right you could
also want to select something bigger
than just
a point
so i think it requires some design there
but i'm i'm kind of thinking that
geographic's pain
or geoposition pain
or even just geopain might be a
possibility
perhaps your location pane if it's going
to return things other than your
positions
yeah okay or geolocator pane
yeah maybe this is the right answer
geolocator pane
just contains the analog of the x
y there and um you know
that's probably the right thing maybe it
was something you'd already suggested
here
i think geolocated paint is the right
idea that would be nice suggestion for
the design
okay okay
um all right next uh look go ahead
no i i was gonna say you know the
dynamic first argument stuff is
pretty easy to do so to get stuff out
like locator pain does so
cool okay
enjoy your tree designs thank you
see you later see ya bye
okay
so this is
billy
yes so we kept the
green selected highlight from last week
and ian had provided some
nice examples for content uh
which we were lacking in last week um
and so there's three
sort of color options to try to get a
feel of
we're going in the right direction or
not all away from
yellow yeah i think these are pretty
decent
i'm going green i'm feeling like going
green here but it's big
um stephen billy pulled me into this
but i didn't understand the different
coloring for the selection highlight
does that mean it has some different
interaction
when you interact with the contents this
year
as opposed to graphics or graph
well it's a different kind of thing just
like graph is a different kind of thing
in terms of interaction i don't think it
has much yet okay
but this is mostly indicating this is
this isn't your average graph
it's a tree okay
now yeah does that mean it will have it
interactions that are different than
graph i just
why is it different than graph visually
why is that important
because it's a different kind of concept
it really has very different structure
a tree just to be clear i mean a tree
all you have to say is what the you know
it requires less information to specify
a tree than a graph
okay i mean
you'll you'll like trees as soon as you
meet them i mean they're they're just
they're not quite the same
yeah um
and actually one big difference from a
graph is the payload of every node is
important on a graph it's just an
annotation but here
it's very often important like
we could um
make um
the um um
[Music]
what am i saying we could we could make
um
uh you know this family tree
um they really not have children over on
this side i didn't know that
it shows my paying attention to the
um anyway
i think maybe that tree just wasn't
filled out properly maybe not maybe the
okay any case no matter um
uh what's my point my point is this
wouldn't be a very exciting family tree
if you know there wasn't labeling on the
nodes
now unfortunately the labeling in the
nodes
you know it's kind of unfortunate that
we have this double border here
we don't have to i mean that's a choice
we make for entities but it's it's a
do you want it visually distinct from
say a label when it's a
it's a known entity
um yes because because most labels don't
have their own framing
labels are just you know the word hello
so to speak and then we do want a box
around it
it's just in these cases of double
boxing i don't know what we do about
those
um
okay
it's kind of dull this one
boom
i don't think we should go as bright as
this i think it could get annoying i
think in
in um
feels like you'd add your own color if
you need it but this was at least
connected back to the selection
highlight
yeah i mean i i think my preference
would be this first one i don't know
what other people think
um i also prefer this one okay
well i think this is the winner would it
be weird to add some
some greenish color to entities or do
they need to stay in the yellow family
i've gotten used to them being yellow
what we mean in in this
case yeah it's used as a label oh yeah
yeah
i don't see why we can't do that and in
here we can if we're recoloring these
we can do whatever we want i mean i
would i would say
in a tree thing just you know
break open the cell cell wall so to
speak
you know there's no reason to have a
double double border here
okay just spill the color into the hole
i'm thinking yeah i mean but but
you know of course what happens if
there's a list of two entities in there
then you're going to need the entity
thing again i don't know whether we can
do this i mean i don't know whether we
can have it break the cell wall
only when it's right there in the
container yeah
do we require entities in other places i
know data set does it
but there's a style sheet i'm assuming
well i know how it's done in data set
but it was then
i think it's controlled in a style sheet
all right well my point of view is if we
have to have a border here
just have it be a really light green so
it will fit in here
i mean look
maybe within this environment it could
just use essentially that green color
there
that background color there
and then you know then it's going to
look more like this which is just fine
somebody needs to be on mute by the way
who isn't
um probably me sorry
oops i am using a new browser today so
i'm going to have different
wrong behaviors
uh yeah okay fine
all right seems like a thing here oh boy
i know i mean all these corner cases of
things like this
i think the generic entity one we should
probably worry about we shouldn't worry
about any of these other cases
okay this one here
what do we want to do about the rounding
radius for a really big
uh you know a big node
what would happen if we if we made it a
more rounded would that look
good or that looks stupid that's
probably not going to work in these
corners
it is more rounded though he's done that
right billy
or have you um
i don't think they are no but
i could oh do you think it would look
sensible guys
you may you mean to make the distinction
clearer
between in your notes and leave now no i
just mean that
i i think this this big slab of
green is a little weird but i don't
really see how to fix it i mean i think
it's
it's some
i mean perhaps it just that it should be
smaller itself
oh i see which has nothing to do with
yeah right right right right right
that's the right answer it has nothing
to do with graphic design
don't worry about the graphic design
it's just a bug in the rendering
make sense ian does that make sense to
you yep
okay yeah i mean in other words
you should try to keep it so that any
thing like this is as small as it can be
while not having the elements crash into
each other
that'll be my suggestion
any composite node is shrunken as small
as it can
while not having its sub nodes crash
into each other
that makes sense yep
okay all right that was it for that
okay onward why do i think this is going
to be a
complicated discussion it is
and and we started this discussion in a
previous meeting
and this is uh and you want to look at
this first why don't we look at this
first it's a bit smaller
um yeah so this is a function that was
suggested in a recent meeting
it's a function to snap numbers to a
grid and
i'm not sure at that point we were
referring to the computation itself
or to the type setting and the type of
do not show all these additional digits
but so this is referring to the
computation so how to
snap numbers target
right i think it's a good concept
this could be useful now the thing is
that
round almost does it except for the fact
that
it requires numbers to i mean the grid
to contain the zero
what is it what's this last argument so
the round
normally
right so some sort of multiple which is
aligned with all other
members of this family like mod quotient
etc
okay so what does it do wrong the
problem is that what happens if
one wants the grid not to contain
zero like for example i only want the
grids of 0.5
so i see what you're saying this thing
is a ruler with with equally spaced
items on it the round thing is a ruler
with equally spaced items as opposed to
what we we do want that but it's a ruler
that contains zero
so what happens if we don't want zero
it's like mod
what happens if mod we want it from -180
to plus 180
not 0 to 360. so mod has this third
argument which is very flexible
very useful and the point is that round
floor and ceiling do not have that
third argument
again explain this to me so so what
would it do for
okay for so imagine that we want this
grid that only returns numbers
which are 0.5 how would we do it with
the round because if we say round
x 0.5 yeah it's going to give 0 0.5 1.
right so we would need a round x
comma 1 comma 0.0 sorry 0.5
right that's the second argument is the
delta x
and the third argument is the offset is
the x zero
exactly
and to make and to make it clear that
this is a perfectly reasonable thing is
that all these five functions can be
written in terms of each
uh for example in terms of floor so you
see here the five functions written
in terms of floor and they all have this
combination of x minus x zero divided by
a
yeah seems to me to make sense we should
just have an offset for each of these
but now um
yeah okay so there probably isn't a role
for snap
right if this is what snap was supposed
to do then i think
this should be a natural generalization
now of course if we want a
multi-dimensional
case then that probably requires a
separate function like for example
mean maxes to coordinate bounds or
ranges to coordinate bounds array
so this is something we have explored a
few times in well a couple of times in
ild
the idea of having multi-dimensional
generalizations of these
numeric functions
what's the point of that well you may
want to have
i mean imagine you have a
table of data and each of these columns
needs
to be snapped to a different grid
so we want to control the grid
independently
why aren't you just doing a round
i mean so you're saying instead of i
don't know what lustability of these is
this this
right now these are all going to be
independently handled right
right i mean if i have if i have a look
yeah just it'll just lustable eyes over
that
right but what if we want a different
delta x for each dimension
so right now at least for this this will
probably work right
but that wouldn't work if we had the
question is it's again one of these
things that's like brought you know the
broadcast problem
right exactly
i think we should think about solving a
problem like this using that mechanism
of um inserted whatever we're going to
call it
okay potentially i don't think it's a
big enough case
to that's that's where i would go with
this initially all right let's
go jump on the trees
go climb the trees okay so our main
problem here that we haven't solved yet
is if we want to map
do we map to the payloads or do we map
to the trees
and how do we distinguish i mean both
operations are useful
and we just need a either separate
functions or a way to specify
one or the other in a given function
all right what is map going to do
what's mapping some what could map on
its own do i mean we we believe that map
on its own will
the most consistent thing to do based on
associations to map onto the payloads
right and i think that's our default
right
um so
tree map maps onto the payloads
and tree map node maps onto this no but
what does map
itself do
we asking what should it do it doesn't
do anything at the moment it doesn't do
anything
um
well i think it should why wouldn't it i
mean on association it does something
right
do i need prototype builder head branch
prototype
okay why shouldn't ordinary map do
something here
in a sense map would have to interpret
the tree
as some particular expression and so we
have this function called
tree expression that allows you to
construct various things or
and there is the opposite expression
three which in interprets expression so
in a sense
it will require a choice of of
interpretation
right so map on a graph doesn't work
right
right
on a graph i would expect it to map onto
the values if it did anything
i think it's the only reasonable thing
for it to do and i do think that will be
a reasonable thing for map to do on a
graph
and arguably something we should have
happen
um
so i mean what i would favor is that
tree map
maps onto subtrees what does association
map do
um
right yeah this is directly analogous
if tree map maps under sub trees and map
just maps onto payloads i think we have
something consistent
so a couple things with map um
like it has this option heads goes to
true
that is kind of specialized to
expressions
thank you and the other hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on
hold on let me think about that for a
second
well i mean heads goes to true doesn't
do anything terribly interested in an
association either
does it
i don't know
well no idea hey what's up with questing
um
puffle that's what i thought it might do
actually
interesting
what will be the analogous thing in
trees
i mean this is in the category of not
terribly useful what's happening there
but probably consistent
okay anyway i think map should go on the
payloads
okay tree map should do the other thing
with map is that its default level spec
is level one and tree map's default
level spec is zero to infinity
which is more useful for trees
well map all is zero to infinity isn't
it
but it's not obvious that that is the
right thing because i mean it might be
that you want to map onto the
leaves of the tree
right i don't know how often you'll want
to map onto leaves versus onto the whole
tree versus onto sub trees
so you're saying tree map would map onto
every level of subtree
by default
it also takes a level spec
what was this fed i don't understand why
this says f of a
what is that a
was the payload of the route okay so
this is doing payload mapping
here which is not what we want
right this is this is doing the opposite
from what we want this is doing what we
want map to do
correct yep
so by default map would just map onto
level one
in the tree correct
level one is the top of the tree correct
no it's the children
is that level zero there yes
oh boy we don't have a level zero for
ordinary map do we
we do it it is the whole expression
okay fine then it's consistent
you can't have a tree that has multiple
roots can you
no consistent
then that then map
well i see consistent so it's gonna it's
it's gonna slightly bizarrely
it would map onto the one level down
right yeah
also i don't think that mapping onto the
payload is really like what map is doing
map is more like mapping to the subtree
how do i go from this carry tree to to a
tree tree
do trees back tick
or actually no just graph tree of that
should work
what the heck is that oh that's because
you don't have tree visualization yet
when are you getting that when is that
going to be the default
we're building it right now
okay all right okay so there it is
so now what are we asking here we're
saying
uh what's what's the analog so we're
saying
it will be tree map is it right i'm
trying to map on to
where's the stream app taking
sub-expressions
tree map will be the payloads
right now it's payloads is that correct
right now it is payloads
okay
map node
what the heck is that so you can't
really tell what's happening because
there's just data structure blobs there
but each one of those is the sub
tree at that particular node
do like f at star tree rules
tree rules or tree visualization tree
visualization should be fine
well except it isn't
that's really funky okay
okay
so what you're saying is the default
here would be normally
what the heck
why doesn't that work
level one
right level specs are not implemented at
the moment
okay there would be yes
i took them out to put in breath first
skin and haven't put it back in
okay
well it's a little bit unclear to me
okay so my
initial take
is that maps should go to the payloads
and tree maps should do the subtrees
okay and that map all is what you would
do if you wanted to map onto the whole
tree
make sense
i mean i could imagine wanting to map
onto the leaves of the tree
but these are all i don't really know
what's going to be common there
well so that could be just level
negative one of course
well list negative one because level
minus one
will go up the whole tree
right level minus one is specified with
list minus one yes correct
okay all right so that's what i think
that's my provisional suggestion here
so now how does tree fold
tree fold instead of having two
different functions like we had for tree
map and tree node
and tree map node it has a optional
argument
okay hold on hold on three what do you
mean different functions we're saying
so tree map and tree map node are the
two different behaviors we're talking
about
yeah right tree fold can do both of them
but it controls it with an optional
argument
rather than by having a treefold node or
something
why doesn't fold just work with with a
graph
i mean fold is for lists
what does fold do in an association it
works just fine doesn't it
no i'm not buying this i'm sorry i'm not
buying it because because then there's
going to be other issues like
i mean maybe tree map and map could be
argued to be the same operation but
treefold cannot be argued to be the same
operation as fold
what does tree fold do it's the thing
that replaces
so you have all these nested trees and
it replaces each use of tree with a
function
why isn't that tree apply
i mean that doesn't strike me as
three-fold at all
i mean we only barely got to discuss
this a little bit last
okay okay fine a generalization of fold
like
fold as a higher order function in
functional programming it'll depend on
what the data structure is that you're
trying to fold and
list has a particular folding operation
okay okay so look the problem is this
fold implies a successor function
it's some kind of iterator with
successor right
yep and that just doesn't exist on a
tree without a traversal order
right so i think what you want here is
tree apply
and that's the thing that would turn
this tree i mean i
yes that is an interesting operation the
the operation that turns the tree
and it's not just apply it's and it's
like uh
recursively applying
to every sub tree
look here's a case here's a case that
might
that comes up in real life okay we've
got a tree it has
unlabeled nodes except it's leaves
okay do you want a real example i'll
give you a real example
i can imagine that um actually i'll give
you an example that just came up
there it is okay so
the way this works is it's a tree
and you start off by putting ones in all
of the leaves
and then you put an operation f at every
node and you propagate it up the tree
you see what i'm saying
interesting so this is folding from the
leaves
yes i mean i've needed to separate
i'm sorry which is what tree fold does
it's a post-order depth first traversal
of the tree
okay but so this is it takes
this is something where it's replacing
the payload here
by the combination of the the payloads
at these leaf nodes and it's recursively
doing that
but it's ignoring every payload that
isn't
well i see if it's a two argument
function it could take in this payload
here
what is it doing no i'm totally confused
now
look there's a thing that is applying
itself to
all the children of a given node
right right
and that's what this is doing and then
that is recursively applying itself to
the children of a node
so it's recursing from the root towards
from the leaves to the root
now what did your operation do
so it also goes from the leaves to the
root
um but it's not like just apply
it i mean one thing is it's not for
mutating a tree
or modifying the tree it's for reducing
a tree to a
value
right but
i think this is an important operation
for example imagine
an artery in which we have many nested
rectangles and we have to find out in
which
whether a point is in one of the
rectangles so the typical thing would be
to start at the root and descend through
the branches
to find out whether it is in one of the
branches so isn't this a natural
three-fold well that's a different issue
yeah
that's one way you're saying i think
that's not a folding operation because
you don't
care about the sub-expressions
it's like an ordinary map
you're traversing the tree
it's not just a map though it's a
pathfinder down the tree
yeah but it doesn't simultaneously need
all of the information from its subtree
to do that
you're you're just walking through the
tree and making a decision
but the decision depends on what has
happened in the previous
right as we go down yeah the parent
needs to know if there was something
found in the child a child
look it seems to me
i'm a little bit confused because given
in this case
any given element has any number of
children right
which are given in its tree
i forget now it's the first or second
argument which one is it
the second argument lists the children
okay
and the first argument is the payload
yes so really this is a three-legged
creature
no maybe it's not
yes it is
no it isn't no it doesn't it's a two
like a creature so
so what you're saying is at any given
stage
say our tree fold takes a function f
and the tree and this stage it takes
f of um
f of current
payload
and child results
right and that's what it returns is that
what you're doing
that is exactly what it is why is there
an arrow there
f a arrow whatever shouldn't be an arrow
where are you seeing an arrow
right there no that's because the
function was
composed with tree rules
i see tree rules put the arrow there
okay i'm no i'm not i'm not agreeing
with this no that's got the tree data
structure there that's not what i'm
saying
look at what i'm saying look at what i'm
saying well because
optional third argument was specified in
that example that you copied
or was it no
oh this is tree map node
oh it's coming completely different
anyway
and so yeah i guess that's not going to
work because
tree visualization doesn't take two
arguments
i'm totally confused by this but okay
but you see what i'm saying
this is what i think it should do and it
sounds like you think it should do that
too
it's basically the the usage message
that i wrote
okay then i agree with that
there's no third argument of anything
it's just that well the third argument
is a function that you
apply to the subtree before you give it
to the function
and by default what it's doing is
getting the payload
like this is saying f of payload comma
the results
and the third argument lets you do
something other than have the payload
there
in particular you could have the subtree
there
and so that i don't care about that case
unless i'm missing something but okay
so i don't i don't reject to the third
argument but i don't care about it
no this looks pretty good although
what this is going to need for the leaf
thing
for the thing where you're where you're
going up from the leaves is it's going
to need a function where if that's
none you do one thing and if that's
a particular value you do a different
thing i mean how do you get this started
at the leaf nodes what does this do
um so at a leaf node it uses an empty
list for the second argument
that was kind of uh more of a finer
design point of
how does like does this even treat
non-terminal leaves and terminal leaves
differently
should there be a different function for
the leaf um
and i urge towards just having the one
function since you can use multiple down
values for f
to have it i know i know but i i think
that it might be convenient
look
if tre-fold we're able to take functions
f and g like this
that might be nice yeah my thought for
that would be that g
would just apply to the payload of
leaves exactly
and f would be a binary function
exactly what internal sub trees
yep exactly
it does make some programming simpler
i think so like the thing i want to do
back on the other page it would just be
g would be one ampersand and f would be
something on hash two
right whereas right now you have to
pretty much if you want to treat the
leaves differently
then you have to define a function f and
give it multiple definitions
i know so this is preferable yeah
okay very nice all right
so these was after the discussion of
map versus stream up and you wanted to
know which other functions put
okay what is tree replaced why is it
different from replace
or replace
what does tree replace do does it
replace subtrees or payloads
and what does replace do on an
association
nothing
okay replace all replaces the payload
what would happen if i said
a goes to one here nothing
okay so i i suspect replace all should
work on trees
and replace payloads
i mean so so one thing is for
trees we want to be able to have a tree
whose payloads
are patterns and then use that tree to
pattern match with another tree
which is so i mean that's just not what
replace does
i understand i think that's a place
where you can use tree replace
to pat and match the tree now pattern
matching the tree is the
is the kind of the quintessential xslt
operation isn't it
i'm not sure well we need to make sure
that those operation operations are
clean
um but i think i mean i would say
replace all replaces payloads
tree replace does subtree replacement
i see so the general idea is that the
existing functions act on payloads
the new functions act on trees
yes
i see so the the positional functions
for which we want to have an extended uh
tree relative rotation
operates on payloads position is asking
where is that payload isn't it
yes what i was thinking is that imagine
position in a tree physician is not
looking for the payloads
it's looking for subtrees
but how do you look for payloads
somehow that would be find me positions
but only if they are used as heads
horrifying why isn't position i mean to
me
like what we have with a tree
corresponds to a whole
expression and so all of our normal
functions like map like if you map at
level one you apply the function
to the whole expression at level one not
just the heads but that's not what we're
saying should happen
right we're saying we should apply it to
the to the payloads
i'm describing how it does work
currently
yeah i think we need to try more cases
i i don't have a good feeling for what's
going on
okay but we do need a principle that for
example position
i mean to me doesn't position work on
payloads in associations
i think the general principle in
association is is
by imitation of a list and
see that that works there perfectly well
for payloads
right but what is the analogy of a tree
for us
i think it's a it's an association with
a some kind of
i mean okay so one way to think about a
tree
it's just an association
with a collection of progressively
longer
sequences of of um coordinates
by making sense yep
and if we did if we thought about it
that way
then our natural
you know whatever is is um
um how is tree an association like
it's like a rule whose right hand side
is an association or
no i'm saying i'm saying that the tree
is as if
it's one one goes to you know element
because every every element in a tree
has a label right so one goes to
whatever
one one you know
those are the tree tree coordinate
positions so it's the thing of positions
to payloads
yes i see
which arguably is a form that we should
allow
as a way to make a tree
which i don't think we have right now
no so i'm claiming that's a possibility
okay hold on
look what does free q do on association
these are
hmm
flatten
how do you get all a list of all the
things that are in payloads
tree data would be the way and what do
you say in tree data
um well
so tree data will have a second argument
that's the same as extract
and it extracts the payloads at the
positions that you give it
i'm sorry so that again so tree data is
like
tree extract except that instead of
extracting the sub tree it extracts the
payload
at the position that you specify
okay when am i going to get to play with
all this stuff
minus tree visualization gonna be built
in
we are working right now on it i'm
hoping that in next few days
okay fine i think we're gonna need to
have more discussion here
and i think you need some cases just
like you did for the thing that billy
was showing
of actual trees right
yeah we do have some examples already of
various sizes of trees
right okay
on the live stream says each time an
initial condition
generates a sub node the sub node
becomes a new function independent of
the functions that generated it
and the final nodes are equivalent
functions of all previous functions
that's a way of generating a tree from a
function
and that's yet a different kind of
operation that's an operation where
instead of generating fold list
you're generating a tree you're it's a
fold tree as opposed to a tree fold
well so there's nest tree what does that
do
it it's you apply a function to
unless it's like nest graph an
expression or to each leaf node in a
tree and then
that's nice yeah
yeah it's like nest graph except that
now what happens
except the tree can no more accept that
it only applies the function to leaf
nodes
whereas nest graph applies the function
to
every vertex and yields a new graph
nest graph takes
yes all existing
vertices and gets their successors
connected to that vertex but then merges
vertices that end up being the same
yep whereas here you're not doing that
yeah we will like if
f returns two at two separate positions
in the tree those are not gonna get
collapsed
so that it stays a tree and the other
difference is that we don't apply the
function anymore
to anything other than leaves
so it's just growing the tree from the
leaves
right all right
well we're making progress here i think
we need to play with some more things
to know that i mean i think you have a
definite idea of what you want to do
with this
i mean i'm you know i'm not certain that
i'm right about this tree map thing and
so on
so if you want to just go ahead and
implement whatever you think you should
implement
if i haven't convinced you that what i'm
suggesting is better
implement whatever you think is best
that's unreasonable okay
i mean i i still recommend you know
whenever it can be modeled on
association model it on association
yeah i think the the main principle we
learn from association is having a
a conversion model that we already know
well
in that case it's a list
right so here i mean we have been
working on the on the assumption that
trees are almost expressions
so what we can learn of the function
working on a general expression
should be imitated for the tree i think
that's right yeah but
this difference of three versus data is
does not exist
in expressions and that's where the
model breaks i know where the payload i
mean expression you could have a payload
hidden in the head but we're not really
you know
there are a few head games that we tend
to play
right
um ac so that's yeah so we have
discussed other times
functionality for operator forms and
things
in which the heads are nested and and
yeah there we get immediately to the
idea that
we need patterns and we need various
things for that case so it
might be related
right that's true yeah that's true
all right we should wrap up here um
so good stuff
all right okay talk to